this morning were paying tribute to one
of our friends and colleagues John
Blackstone he is stepping away from his
impressive Emmy award-winning career to
enjoy more time with his family he's
still gonna report for us occasionally
John joins CBS News in 1980 as a foreign
correspondent he travelled the world to
cover wars and coos civil unrest and
natural disasters John transferred to
San Francisco in 1986 and he followed
the evolution of the tech industry
covered wildfires and caught up with
lots of celebrities John's good friends
60 minutes correspondent Bill Whitaker
highlights John's unique way of
reporting that makes him one of a kind
runway to up you kiddo up to go Don
Blackstone's passion for storytelling
compelled him to push the limits drawer
Denari adventures were his specialty
he starts by falling backwards out of a
helicopter for close to four decades
John was always on the go there's now
just four inches of glass between my
feet certain death at the bottom of the
Grand Canyon
his CBS career began in 1980 reporting
from conflicts and hotspots around the
world what they don't know is how soon
the change will come or how violently of
course he didn't mind hitting the cold
spots either here at the South Pole the
enormity of the Antarctic Ice Sheet is
striking its ice so thick it buries
entire Antarctic mountain ranges from
his base in San Francisco John kept his
eyes and ears on advancements in the
tech industry cell phones and iPods
laptops and blackberries
who needs yet another device that does
many of the same things from wildflowers
to wildlife Wow to wildfires embers fall
on another house blown in by these
strong winds start another fire John is
a master at setting the scene in
Montana's Bitterroot
not only does a River run through it
when the fly fisherman is Huey Lewis a
rhythm runs through it
John Blackstone is that The Price is
Right studio in Los Angeles and this set
for more than 40 years The Price is
Right has been giving away fabulous
prizes let's do this a try but perhaps
most memorable is the personal average
guy connection John makes with the
people in his stories would you call
that one more complicated or less
complicated than this way I call you
more okay do I understand that your
first date he didn't take you to see a
movie he took you to see a movie and the
teacher can always tell what you're
doing he's like a hawk and in every
story John had a way of saying a lot by
saying so little
apparently Nick and Kristen's videos
have convinced a lot of people to take
up skateboarding but not John Blackstone
CBS News Shingle Springs California
well John from all of us at CBS News we
thank you for so many early mornings
late nights and for great storytelling
and reporting all around thank you
[Music]